as we descend from the heavens of
philosophical discussion of conservatism
and liberalism let's go to the pragmatic
muck of
politics Trump versus Biden between the
two of them who was in their first term
uh the better president and thus who
should win if the two of them are in
fact our choices should win a second
term in
20124 Ben sure so in terms of actual
performance you have to separate it into
a few categories uh in terms of actual
performance in foreign policy I think
Trump's foreign policy record is
significantly better than Biden's the
world being on fire right now being
fairly good example of that uh and we
can get into each aspect of the world
being on fire and where the incentive
structures came from and how all of that
happened in a moment when it comes to
the economy I think that Trump's
economic record was better than Biden's
doesn't mean he didn't overspend he did
he wildly overspent uh but he also had a
very solid record of job creation a huge
percentage of the gains in the economy
went to people on the lower end of the
economic spectrum actually uh the gross
income to the average American was about
$6,000 during his term the unemployment
rates were very very low before covid
you I think that you almost have to
separate the Trump Administration into
sort of before Co and during covid
because Co obviously is sort of a Black
Swan event the the most signal change in
in politics in our lifetime uh and so
you know governance during Co is almost
its own category which we can discuss um
but you know in terms of foreign policy
in terms of domestic policy I think that
Trump was significantly better than than
Biden has been and that's on the upside
for Trump on the downside for Biden
obviously you're talking 40e highs in
inflation you're talking about savings
being eaten away you're talking about
everything being 20 to 30 30% more
expensive you're talking about massive
increases to the deficit even at a rate
that was unknown under Trump the deficit
under Trump raised by about a little
under a trillion dollars every year up
until 20120 again 2020 was Co year so
everybody decided that we were going to
fire hose money at things um but uh then
Joe Biden continued to fire hose money
at things in 21 22 and 23 uh you know
that obviously is in my opinion bad
Economic Policy uh and then you get to
the rhetoric and you get to the stuff
that Donald Trump says and as I've said
before my view is that on Donald Trump's
half on his gravestone it will say
Donald Trump he said a lot of uh I
I think that Donald Trump does say a lot
of things I think that that is basically
baked into the cake which is why
everyone who's bewildered by the polls
is ignoring human nature which is at the
beginning when you see something very
shocking it's very shocking and then if
you see it over and over and over and
over for years on end it is no longer
shocking it is just part of the
background noise like tontis it just
becomes you know something that your
brain adjusts for uh and so do I like a
lot of Donald Trump's rhetoric no and I
never have do I think that that is just
positive as to his presidency no I do
not when it comes to Biden again I think
he's underperforming economically I
think that his foreign policy has been
really a a problem even the things I
think he's done right are I think
bandaids for things that he created by
doing wrong uh and when it comes to his
his own
rhetoric you can argue that it's grading
on a curve because Trump was coming in
with such wild rhetoric that just a
maintenance of that wild rhetoric
doesn't really change again the Baseline
for Biden he came in in the same way
that Obama did on the sort of soaring
rhetoric of American Unity I'm the
president for all like Trump came in
he's like listen I'm the president for
for what I am and you know I'm going to
say the things I want to say I'm be on
the toilet and I'm tweeting we're like
okay you know that's what it is with
Biden he came in with I'm a president
for all Americans I'm trying to unify
everybody and that pretty quickly broke
down into a lot of oppositional language
about his political opponents in
particular and attempt to lump in for
example huge swaths of the conservative
movement with the people who
participated for example in January 6th
or who are fans of January 6th um and um
you know the the the sort of lumping in
of everybody into Mago Republicans who
wasn't personally signed on to an
infrastructure bill with him that sort
of stuff I think has been truly terrible
I thought his Philadelphia speech was
truly terrible and again I think that
you do have the problem of he is no
longer capable of certainly rhetorically
unifying the country when every speech
from him feels like watching Nick Wenda
walk across a volcano on a tight RPP it
really is like you're just sort of
waiting for him to follow I mean it's
it's sad to say I mean the other day he
was speaking for what was in effect his
campaign kickoff and this is in Valley
Forge uh and I mean Jill rushed up there
like off that off the as soon as he was
done Jill rushed up there uh you know
like she'd been shot out of a cannon to
to come and try and guide him away so he
didn't become the Shane Gillis Roomba
and you know that that's not really you
know I let's put it this way it does not
quiet the soul to watch Joe Biden
rhetorically again that's a different
problem than Trump's problem but that
that's my
analysis